herzlich willkommen zu diesem seminar
ich sehe es sehr viele da das freut mich
ich lasse zu beginn gleich die
seminarteilnehmer liste durchgehen die
sie sich bitte eintragen mit nach name
und vorname und dann der e-mailadresse
weil ich regelmäßige zusammenfassung
herumschicken einige von ihnen sind mir
bekannt
die teilnehmer die schon mal meinen
seminaren waren wissen dass ich
regelmäßig e-mails herumschicken einer
verteilerliste und ich lasse auch schon
mal hier gleich auf der anderen seite
den vorläufigen sitzungsplan herumgehen
der wird wahrscheinlich nicht reichen
aber es ist nicht schlimm weil ich
nämlich eine digitale struktur
entwickelt habe die alle informationen
enthält die auch in diesem seminar
thematisch sind es gibt eine app die
viel oka step die muss ich jedes mal
bewerben und die können sie sich jetzt
schon
ich möchte sie ermutigen m auf ich
möchte ihm anregen dazu die sich jetzt
herunter zu laden gleich sieht so aus
gibt es kostenlos im store an android
und apple und für diejenigen unter ihnen
die jetzt keine teile seminar liste
heute mehr abbekommen sollte weil ich
habe nur 20 ausgedruckt die finden die
schon hier auf der app als diesen
seminarplan und zwar hier in einem neuen
menü das heißt dann theorien der
kausalität da ist es schon drin
genau also das ist eine app die möchte
ich ihnen sehr ans herz legen weil sie
in dieser app eben nicht nur immer auf
dem neuesten stand bleiben ich schicke
über die app und über die e-mail ist
immer die seminar zusammenfassung herum
also auch der heutigen sitzung muss
gleich dazu sagen ich nehme die sitzung
auch auf audio mäßig habt ihr mikrofon
trat sie das wissen also wenn sie sich
melden werden sie auch aufgezeichnet das
mache ich zu dokumentationszwecken ich
sage sie nur dass sie es wissen und sie
können die dann auch nach höheren ich
stelle ihnen auch ins internet
diese jeweiligen sitzung nur damit sie
es wissen
auf diese app finden sie zum beispiel
auch videos also die app ist nicht nur
mein jetziges seminar angeboten sondern
auch an meinem seminar was ich jetzt
gestern gegeben habe zum ersten mal über
theorien der zeit was ist zeit
da finden sie auch ganz analog diesem
seminar die zusammenfassung und die
audioaufnahmen und sonstige dinge auch
in einem neuen menü punkt hier im
inhaltsverzeichnis und finden dann alle
einträge dazu mit wenigen tipps
es gibt auch auf dieser diese app gibt
es auch antritt dinge noch zum beispiel
quizze das ist dann durch so ein symbol
veranschaulicht ich mache auch manchmal
themen sendungen also mit wird meinen
mitarbeitern zu bestimmten themen
vielleicht mache ich mal eine themen
sendung dauert immer so drei bis fünf
minuten zum thema qualität wenn sie
wünsche haben kann ich das auch noch
einrichten also das ist die app und die
dürfen sich sehr gerne jederzeit auch
auf dem tisch vor sich haben sie dürfen
auch gerne mit
also um operieren sage ich mal weil die
app so strukturiert ist dass jeder
beitrag in einem wiki system angebunden
ist so dass bestimmte begriffe die im
wiki enthalten sind hypertext ul
verbunden sind also manche begriffe oder
namen zum beispiel immanuel kant der
taucht dann ein
zusammenfassung die sie hier sehen
können blau unterlegt blau unterstrichen
auf dann tippen sie auf kant und kommen
sie zum wiki eintrag bekannt dann finden
sie ein paar biografische informationen
und im beitrag von cannes finden sie
dann wieder ein hyper textuellen verweis
auf die card und so können sie sich dann
hypertext will springend mäzens diese
ganze debatte erschließen
hat sich jemand von ihnen schon die app
gerade heruntergeladen funktioniert sie
darin mahlgrad bitten um wortmeldungen
einfach nur anhand zeichen wer sich die
app schon geholt hat funktioniert sie ja
hier gibt's schon im menü ein tag
okay okay aber an einem tag haben sie
gesehen schon neun menüeintrag theorien
der kausalität und da müsste auch dieser
plan prinz sein hinterlegt sein
also und der vorteil dieser digitalen
struktur ist der dass sie immer den
aktuellen seminarplan haben also ich
werde werde gleich auf den inhalt zu
sprechen kommen wir werden
erfahrungsgemäß uns nicht genau daran
halten können manchmal brauchen wir für
eine sitzung mehr zeit selten weniger
wir nehmen vielleicht noch einen neuen
text hinzu wenn sie sich nicht sicher
sind was wir in der jeweiligen sitzung
machen
schauen sie sich einfach mal die app an
und dann haben sie dort den aktuellsten
plant drin
ich werde auch sage ich jetzt gleich
noch jeweils push notification
herumschicken also ein vibriert ihr
smartphone wundern sie sich nicht dann
bin ich es der ihnen mal wieder hier was
geschickt hat ist also ein seminar für
die großen taschen zum beispiel wenn sie
in der u-bahn sind mal wieder fällt die
u-bahn aus oder sie steht im stau oder
im bus oder ich weiß nicht was dann
schauen sie einfach mal kurz auf die app
und bereiten sich dann noch kurz vor
allem seminar zusammenfassung aktuelle
semester plan aufzeichnung quizze die
ihn auch eine automatische rückmeldung
geben
vielleicht werde ich auch noch in der
mitte des semesters einen freiwilligen
kurztest anbieten da sie mal eine
rückmeldung bekommen aber die krise
geben den automatischen rückmeldung
dessen häufigste multiple choice test
also müssen sie einen oder mehrere
zutreffend antworten anklicken vom am
smartphone direkt und bekommen dann eine
rückmeldung
über links ein wiki dann habe ich noch
im youtube kanal der heißt auch viele
cast und können sie gerne auch mal drauf
schauen auch in das projekt das jetzt so
gut ein jahr schon läuft hat schon fast
500 abonnenten und da habe ich da die
regelmäßigen sendung oder auch
aufzeichnungen von vorträgen von
tagungen die größtenteils von mir
organisiert wurden aber auch von anderen
tagung oder jemals ein experten
interview mit jemandem von der fsk
freiwilligen freiwilligen
selbstkontrolle über das böse schauen
sie einfach mal rein wir haben da ein
ganzes angebot und das wird auch
regelmäßig aktualisiert soviel zur
digitalen strukturen
jetzt komme zum inhalt kausalität und da
kann man sich mehrere fragen überleben
ich will jetzt nicht erschöpfend hier an
die wand projizieren aber ich möchte mal
einige punkte nennen die für uns von
interesse sein werden also zunächst
einmal fragen hier was sind eigentlich
ursachen was sind willkommen also
kausalität ist ja immer ein relation und
zwar eine zweistellige relation diese
relation kürzt man ja mit dem großen
erraten steht in der relation zu b
das ist die relation und dass beide sind
relativ im verhältnis stehen entität als
ein reh hat oma und ich sag nur also ein
relativ moderater
so und er ist jetzt eben k also kaufte
bestimmten eine beziehung der kausalität
der verursachung und dann ist es klar
dass er natürlich die ursache ist und b
die wilken das als eine zweistellige
relation es gibt noch andere
zweistellige relationen weiß jemand was
noch mit zweistellige relation ist was
was für verhältnisse gibt es noch die
zweistellig sind genau genau größer
kleiner usw gibt auch noch einen ganz
interessanten anderen fall
die identität ist mit sich selbst
identisch könnte man auch als eine
zweistellige relation bezeichnen jaha
steht im verhältnis zu sich selbst der
identität jedenfalls jetzt haben wir ein
bisschen formalisiert oder ein bisschen
logisch dass ganze modelliert das wollen
wir auch tun wir sind ja ein master
seminar nicht genau gibt es unter ihnen
auch jemand der bachelor studiert und
dieses fortgeschritten sind am 8 okay
wer macht master okay also 50 50 okay
also ich will masters seminar ist dann
schon ein bisschen anspruchsvoller als
ein bachelor seminar aber ich will es
trotzdem so arm ausrichten das seminar
ist wirklich jetzt nicht allzu viele
voraussetzungen hier erfordert werden
ich muss allerdings sagen da komme ich
gleich darauf dass insofern dieses
niveau hier ein bisschen höher ist als
in einem bachelor seminar als wir hier
einige texte auf englisch lesen werden
im englischen original das ist eben im
vergleich zu einem bachelor seele hat
dann die sag ich mal
der höhere anspruch
ich bin immer der meinung im englischen
original kann man es einfach doch noch
besser verstehen aber wir müssen
wirklich da dann auch uns sehr viel mühe
geben wenn sie wollen aber es werde ich
später noch sagen kann ich auch
versuchen noch parallel deutsche
übersetzung aufzutreiben
aber die gibt es eben nicht von allen
englischen texten
das ist das problem weil wir eben einige
englische texte lesen werden nicht nur
also was sind ursachen wirkungen so das
ist die frage was ist denn jetzt
eigentlich und b&o logisch logisch
schauen was jetzt bestimmt logisch ist
da und b ein rollator
aber was ist es ontologisch was gibt es
für möglichkeiten was für entitäten
könnten und wie sein
ja
menschenwürde
könnte man sagen ja also gott als
ursache so zu sagen ja das ist immer mal
wieder auch in der geschichte der
philosophie vertreten worden
diese these zb lowcost journalismus das
ist eine neuzeitliche theorie die
versucht die kausalität zu erklären oder
wenn sie mal so ein prinzip den
allerersten anfang allen was alle dessen
was existiert sich anschauen dann wird
er häufig auch gott begriff gottes ins
spiel gebracht denken sie aber jetzt mal
eher mal im tramuntana also jetzt hier
auf dieser welt was was für typen von
entitäten könnte jetzt a und b seien als
würden sie sagen die veränderung ist
eine entität oder sollte man vielleicht
dann sagen ein prozess also dass man so
diesen typ von entität bestimmt ok also
ich habe hier das wäre die logik so ein
bisschen nicht nicht nur was ein
bisschen die logos die ontologie
anthologie was könnte jetzt also a und b
seien also prozesse
was gibt es noch für möglichkeiten
es geht einfach jetzt um die
begrifflichkeit mal dass man sagt was
ist anders b
man könnte doch jetzt mal ganz banal
sagen das sind dinge das ding a
verursacht das ding b aber da gibt es
den gleichen problem was ist das problem
wenn ja ist ein ging die ursache ist ein
ding ich kann ja sagen
die personal tötete ein wenig tötete
sagte der löwe fraß das dass das bbs ist
der löwe war es für den tod verursacht
also verantwortlich des rehs können wir
sagen die ursache ist der löwe
das ging das existieren was ist das
problem davon
ich sage dir da sind dinge
diesen haben kann
genau die sind ja auch wieder drin das
wäre dann eher so hätten da gar nicht
die frage eigentlich beantwortet ja
[Musik]
als wir scheinen einfach über den dingen
begriff diese diese kraft die in der
kausalität enthalten ist dieser relation
nicht richtig zu fassen
haben sie noch andere ideen kandidaten
für diese regatta was was das sein
könnte also prozesse ist jetzt eine
möglichkeit gebe ich einfach noch ein
paar punkte also dinge mache jetzt mal
dinge ist wirklich ein problem dinge ein
fragezeichen
also zum beispiel ich kann ja sagen die
ursache für das herunterfallen diese
stiftes ist das loslassen des stiftes
ist das loslassen des stiftes ein ding
das könnte das loslassen des stiftes
sein
ein ereignis zum beispiel prozess
durchaus auch aber also prozess der
prozess des loslassens des fingers in
dieser situation
man könnte auch sagen ereignis was
könnte man noch sagen was ist noch da
und wie also das ereignis des loslassens
und sagte das ereignis des
herunterfallen ist ja ja
als mein sind die gedanken bei mir im
kopf dass ich ihn loslassen will oder
ach so ok ja richtig aber dann wäre ja
auch ein gedanke ein ereignis der eine
gedanke dass eine gedanken ereignis
verursacht das andere oder für das
antreten und gedanken ereignis nach sich
was gibt es noch denken sie ihr mann
ludwig wittgenstein sagt den
wittgenstein
die welt ist genau und nicht die welt
der dinge sondern die welt der ich habs
grad nicht verstanden
ja dann könnte durchaus noch hier fragen
phänomen das ist jetzt aber könnte der
fall ist und das was der fall es ist
eine genau zahl ja also welches problem
haben sie jetzt wenn sie jetzt sich mal
so eine kausalität relation überlegen
aber verursacht b klassischerweise
bringt man da immer so das anstoßen
einer billardkugel die dann auf eine
andere billard kugel trifft verursacht
deren bewegungen eine andere richtung
das ist so das klassische kausalität
modell das auch immanuel kant häufig
verwendet auf den wir gleich noch zu
sprechen kommen und auch david hume den
wir auch behalten
also dieses stoß diese wirklich
mechanische einwirkung auf ein objekt
was dann wiederum ein anderes irgendwie
in bewegung setzt zwar in bewegung
setzen der veränderung hervorgeht was
ist in diesem modell enthalten diese
causa modell was bei so einem modell von
tatsachen nicht mehr so gut bewahrt
bleibt wie intuition wird dann nicht
mehr so gut eingefangen
überlegen sie mal wenn man kausalität
immer so versteht als etwas was auch mit
kräften zu tun hat
oder haben oder mach das mal anders
welches diese welche dieser anthologie
bevorzugen sie wenn wir jetzt mal
nachgefragt also nach dem status nach
der beschaffenheit der kategorie der
regatta machen eine umfrage wer von
ihnen ist der meinung einfach mal kurz
melden
sie können sich auch mehr mehrmals mit
mehr ist der meinung dass ammer und b
die relativ prozesse sind eine
kausalität situation er ist der meinung
dass es dinge sind er ist der meinung
dass ereignisse sind
wer ist der meinung dass es phänomene
sind okay und dass es tatsachen sind als
ereignisse ist ist der ist vor allem
jetzt erstmal so der hat am meisten
stimmen bekommen das muss nicht sein
dass das jetzt dann der einzige kandidat
ist also mein problem was ich immer hat
mit ereignis oder mit tatsachen ist das
da in meinen augen diese kraft die in
dieser ursache steckt ist ja eine kraft
gelegt irgendwie an ein potenz eine
potenz ein potenzial was wie irgendwie
verursacht und 80 zieht dass das bei der
bloßen rede von tatsachen zumindest mir
ein bisschen zu kurz kommt also das
finde ich es für meinen geschmack wir
werden das noch genau nun etwas zu
schwach
wir sagen eine ursache hat immer eine
potenz eine möglichkeit eine gewisse
kraft ausübung und das ganze
das wird dann bei der rede in der rede
von tatsachen für meinen geschmack
zumindest etwas zu wenig berücksichtigt
ereignisse durchaus
das 3 jetzt habe ich hier mal ein index
angeführt bei a und b arbeit t1 t2 also
wir können jetzt hier dann auch noch
fragen nach der zeit zeigt jetzt stellt
sich die es gibt drei möglichkeiten sie
haben jetzt eine these schon vertreten
bezüglich der zeitlichkeit der renate
also ich kann jetzt fragen nach der zeit
dieser diese verhältnisse zeitlichkeit
gibt es mehrere möglichkeiten was für
möglichkeiten gibt es denn jetzt
bezüglich t1 und t2
der zeitliche relation genau man kann es
so fassen muss es aber auch nicht
unbedingt jetzt wenn man es mal zeitlich
fassen was wäre dann das verhältnis von
t1 und t2 also wie würden sich die
rheinenser t2 zueinander verhalten
welche möglichkeiten gibt es sie haben
schon mit einer these vertreten sie
haben gesagt t2 ist größer als die 1
also dass man sagt die zeit der wirkung
an der zeitpunkt des eintretens der
wirkung ist später als der zeitpunkt des
ereignisses der tatsache die ursachen
also wäre es eine möglichkeit also t2
ist größer als 1 es gibt eine
möglichkeit
bitte gebt könnte man sich zumindest
vorstellen
die 11 gleich die 2 das gibt es noch
eine möglichkeit
zum beispiel werden hier einst länger
andere wie soll ich das formalisieren
haben sie die möglichkeit wie ich es
darstellen könnte modellieren könnte
eine teilmenge aber es gibt noch eine
dritte möglichkeit die auch wenn sie
noch so verrückt klingen mag wir müssen
sie erörtern
ja genau
also das g2 oder so wir das t1 größer
als die zwei ist das müssen wir
zumindest als philosophen und
philosophinnen müssen wir diese
möglichkeit immer auch berücksichtigt
wir müssen uns fragen warum muss denn
jetzt gerade t2 größer als t1 halten
kann ich die wirkung vor der ursache zu
gibts sowas wie rückwärts gewandte
kausalität thema zeitreise dass ich also
in die vergangenheit hin kausal pfeile
entsenden
das praktisch die zukunft die
vergangenheit beeinflussen thema
zeitreisen
ich gebe ja auch ein seminar wird was
ist zeit und wir werden da auch als ein
bachelor seminar auch so was wie wie die
logik die paradoxien von zeitreisen
behandeln und es scheint zwar eher
unwahrscheinlich zu sein dass so etwas
möglich ist aber muss es mit allen
konsequenzen durch dinge also zeit und
kausalität hängen ganz eng miteinander
zusammen also müssen uns zum beispiel
auch wagen ist sind a und b zeitlich
sind sie zeitlich verfasst oder sind sie
nur logisch verfasst gibt es kaum
sanität die nicht zeitlich ist nicht
zeitliche verursachung wer von ihnen
glaubt dass es nicht zeitliche
verursachen gibt einfach mal melden
und sie haben einen guten gewährsmann
immanuel kant immanuel kant auf den wir
gleich gekommen
das sagt es gibt so was wie nicht
zeitliche kausalität also das meine ich
jetzt einfach mit dem philosophischen
zucker und die physiker gar nichts gegen
physiker die würden hier nur eine
begrenzte menge an fragen überhaupt in
betracht ziehen einfach aus
methodologischen gründen wir
philosophinnen philosophen müssen noch
einen schritt weiter gehen
wir sind nicht auf experimente
angewiesen wir machen
gedankenexperimente wir stellen uns alle
fragen die nur irgend möglich selbst
wenn sie auf anhieb erst mal verrückt
klingen das ist unsere aufgabe als
philosophin und philosophen also scheuen
sie nicht meine verrückte frage zu
stellen könnte nicht die ursache früher
seien die später sein als die wirkung so
solche fragen müssen uns getrauen zu
stellen könnte es nicht eine ursache
geben ohne wirkung ein verhältnis von
beiden die nicht in der zeit stattfindet
die zeitlos sind alles möglich also
alles schon mal vertreten worden es gibt
nichts was nicht schon mal in der
philosophiegeschichte vertreten wurde
also das ist ein riesen komplex dann
eine weitere frage wie können wir die
kausalität relation formalisieren ich
habe jetzt hier schon mal so ein versuch
gemacht nun mal die relation so ein
bisschen zu klären aber natürlich dann
kann man sich jetzt fragen und b also
den adern b kann man kausalität zu
formalisieren wenn adam b also als
hinreichende bedingung für b also als
applikation
das würde ich sagen
ja genau
also wenn er nicht gewesen wäre dann
wäre auch nicht mehr die notwendige
bedingung ist wenn adam b tja also
solche fragen also prima fazit würden
viele sagen wenn adam ii
als ursache wie die wirkung wenn man es
nicht logisch macht sind also alltag
sprachlich kann man das so machen wenn a
führt zu gehen dann kann man sich aber
fragen ja hätte nicht auch bezieher
führen können oder de kann eine wirkung
verschiedene ursachen haben also
erzählen sie gleich willkommen ist ein
riesen frage komplex
sie sehen hier spielt jetzt plötzlich
auch die logik eine rolle
ich habe jetzt a ich habe bgh jetzt mal
die wirkung also die ursache dieses
technologische formalisierung nur so
eine veranschaulichung also a kann und
die ursache von besen oder wir
verursachen kann aber nicht cdb
verursachen sind das dann alles ursachen
von b sie könnten alle hinreichend seien
aber nicht notwendig sein
oder man kann diesen vorfall vorstellen
wo nur c und d zusammen wie verursachen
also für sich genommen notwendig aber
nicht hinreichend sind und nur das ganze
dann hinreichend ist also damit will ich
nur sagen es gibt da ganz viele
möglichkeiten sich diese diese
kausalität relation vorzustellen immer
vor dem hintergrund der frage was jetzt
eigentlich abc.de eigentlich ist sind
das ereignisse sind es tatsachen sind
das dinge sind dass kräfte das gibt es
nämlich auch noch als wäre diese diese
ding diese dinge ontologie der
kausalität relation würde sagen da ist
eine kraft heißt eine substanz die eine
kraft ausübt auf eine andere substanz
das ist eine spannende frage wie sollen
die kausalität modellieren logisch dass
es eine hinreichende notwendig oder ist
es sogar noch eine viel komplexere viel
komplexeres verhältnis aus hinreichenden
und notwendigen bedingungen
das ist die logik der pausentee die
erste frage die ich jetzt hier dran
geworfen habe ist die frage nach der und
logie
der qualitäts redaktion was sind
ursachen das ist die ontologie diese
möglichkeiten auch ereignisse sind
eigentlich dinge könnte wasser oder
etwas was existiert es man kann es nicht
anfassen ein ereignis oder man kann es
schon anfassen aber vom typ her ist es
nicht dinge haft vorgestellt und die
zweite frage ist die logische dimension
der kausalität redaktionen wie können
wir sie formalisieren sind ursachen
notwendige hinreichende bedingung oder
komplexe verhältnisse von notwendigkeit
und hinreicht hinreichend den relationen
das wollen wir behandeln
weitere fragestellungen ist die ist
kausalität ein onkologisches ergänze
logisches oder ein psychologisches thema
also die frage ist hier die wie können
wir kausalität erkennen ist es nicht so
dass wir nicht vielmehr die kausalität
relation in die welt nur
hineinprojizieren überlegen sie machen
sie denn machen die beobachtung dass auf
den auf das ereignis immer wieder ein
ereignis des typs b folgt also ein
beispiel
hier erklingt immer in diesem raum um 12
uhr 45 in einem signalton und immer ganz
genau fünf minuten danach um 12 uhr 50
fliegt hier in diesem raum ein blauer
vogel hinein
woche für woche
dann könnten sie überlegen warum ist das
so und dann läge der schluss sehr
schnell nahe
ein fazit das der signalton den vogel
irgendwie angelockt hat und was die
ursache ist für das hineinfliegen des
vogels
jetzt können sich das beliebig anders
überlegen bin sieht sehr häufig die
beobachtung machen das auf eine eigenes
des typs a ein ereignis des typs b folgt
dann werden sie irgendwann zu dem
schluss kommen dass das ereignis a die
ursache des ereignisses b ist sie haben
da eine regulierte immer wenn adam b
oder a und b treten immer eine gewisse
konstanz auf und sie würden sich nicht
damit begnügen dass sagen da steht in
einer gewissen regelmäßigen koinzidenz
mit bbb mieter sondern sie würde noch
einen schritt weiter gehen und sagen als
die ursache von b dieser schluss liegt
auf der hand irgendwann wenn sie nur
häufig genug eine regula ried wahrnehmen
würden sie sagen das ist eine ursache
und das ist nun gekommen
ein anderes beispiel ist gibt es zum
beispiel in england immer wenn die uhr
eine kirchturmuhr 16 uhr schlägt dann
gehen alle arbeiter aus den fabriken aus
den türen heraus und steigen in die
pause regelmäßig ist jetzt das turm
geläut ursächlich für das herausgehen
der arbeiter die busse offensichtlich
nicht
also es gibt korrelationen es gibt
verhältnisse die sehr regelmäßig sind
aber dennoch nicht kausal wirksam sind
ich glaube es hat sich jetzt immer noch
gemeldet habe ich jemanden jahr
betreffen
also rein logisch steht man das
wenn man wenn wir sagen die zwei größer
als tennis oder t1 groß heißt die zwei
geht auch da müsste man es auch
andersrum an dem
genauso wir müssen erst mal alles offen
lassen hier ja also wir gehen jetzt
erstmal natürlich vom fall aus das ist
ein sonderfall
also wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon
aus dass t2 größer als die 1 ist oder
tee 1 gleich die zwei hier mache ich mir
ein dickes fragezeichen aber wir müssen
diesen fall auch bewegen
immanuel kant zum beispiel sagt t1 und
t2 können auch gleich groß sein
er bringt das beispiel wenn ich eine
kugel eine schwere kugel in ein kissen
liegen
dann tritt mit dem einlegen der kugel
die verformung des kissens 1
das geht hand in hand solche sachen
das ist ein beispiel wie ich ein
paradigma ist hier kant anhängig wenn
sie mal dieses kugel beispiel neben
welchem paradigma würde er eher hier
folgen kugel und kissen ja
wurde vielleicht sogar dinge dass die
das kissen ist eingestellt das ist schon
fast so das eingestellte kissen das ist
fast schon so ein theologisches thema
wasser natürlich nicht direkt vertreter
aber er bringt diese beispiel kann sagt
also es ist möglich man kann sich diesem
fall durchaus vorstellen dass die einst
gleich die zwei ist diesen kissens
beispiel von kissen also ich wollte
jetzt damit sagen also regula riten also
im legen uns nahe bringen fazit dass es
sich dabei um eine kausalität relation
handeln könnte jetzt kann man sagen ist
das nicht nur eine projektion projektion
von uns in die welt ist die kausalität
relation nur so eine überlebenshilfe die
uns unsere natur die lange
evolutionsgeschichte in das gehirn
eingepflanzt hat damit wir uns einfach
in der welt dieser unübersichtlichen
mannigfaltigkeit von ereignissen besser
orientieren können dass wir sagen ja gut
das sind typen von ursachen das sind
typen von wirkung ist es nicht
eigentlich nur eine projektion oder eine
vielleicht sogar nur illusion gibt es
gar nicht kausalität diese frage müssen
wir auch hier als philosophin und
philosophen in erwägung ziehen
und das ist dann die apps theologischen
frage nach der qualität können wir sie
erkennen die und logische frage wäre
dann natürlich auch noch gibt es
überhaupt das andere frage
man kann nämlich auch noch sagen die
gibt es gar nicht gibt es gar nicht
es ist nur so ne eine hilfskonstruktion
um in der welt überleben zu können
man könnte auch noch folgendes sagen es
gibt gar keine kausalität im strengen
sinne es gibt nur wahrscheinlichkeiten
denken sie an die quantenphysik und so
weiter und so fort an die kleinsten
teilchen pro partie ließ tische theorien
der kausalität nennt man das auch das
ist eine möglichkeit über kausalität für
so fisch zu sprechen
spannende frage auch noch die mich
persönlich sehr interessiert gibt es
verschiedene arten von kausalität von
ursachen und wirkungen oder nur eine art
haben sie mit blick auf die
philosophiegeschichte eine idee was für
arten von kausalität es geben könnte
denken sie mal in die antike an die
antike denken sie mal an aristoteles ja
der posten war
genau genau genau also aristoteles
es gibt verschiedene arten von
kausalität es gibt nicht nur eine wir
neuzeitlichen sagen es gibt nur eine art
von kausalität die effizienz kausalität
die ursache wirkungs kausalität
es gebe noch andere formen von käthi
zweck ursache die theologische ursache
das ist also zweck ursache es gebe noch
die formale usa es gebe noch die
materiale ursache und daneben die
wirkung sache also wir moderne denken
kausalitäten der regel als wird ursache
ein bisschen mechanisch mechanistisch
das formen irgendwelche ursachen
ursachen sind für andere wirkungen
formen das ist uns heute etwas fremd
geworden aber es wurde vertreten immer
anerkannt
mein lieblings philosoph auf den wir
auch noch mehr eingehen werden im laufe
des semesters der sagt es gibt eine ganz
ganz seltsame art von kausalität und die
nennt der kausalität aus freiheit kann
sagt es gibt zwei formen von kausalität
es gibt eine kausalität tritt in der
natur auf das ist diese effizienz
kausalität final qualität also zweck
ursächlichkeit dass etwas in der natur
etwas will sage ich jetzt mal der
anstrebt das ist sehr problematisch sagt
in der natur gilt das wirkliche
mechanistische kausalität prinzip ua
verursacht b in der freiheit die wir
auch noch denken müssen da gilt eine
kausalität aus freiheit das ist die
möglichkeit dass wir trotz aller
natürlichen determination dadurch dass
wir die natur gesetz gesetz muss hier
vielleicht noch hinstellen und gesetz
gesetz
es sind instanzen eines gesetzes das
naturgesetz dass alles was existiert
ursache und wirkung als ursachen hat und
wirkung ist dass trotz dieser
vollständigen kausal determination der
welt wir menschen die wir auch
natürliche wesen sind dennoch frei
handeln können aus diesem zusammenhang
diesen gesetzlichen zusammenhang die
natur heraustreten können in gewisser
weise und selbst zwecke setzen können
die nicht wiederum von anderen ursachen
der natur verursacht sind dass wir
letztendlich über der natur
gesetzlichkeit stehen und das sagt auch
eine form von gesetzlichkeit das ist die
freiheits gesetzlichkeit eine kausalität
aus freiheit sagt kant ist das kann sagt
es gebe zweifel von kausalität
aristoteles sagt es gibt vier form von
kausalität die meisten heutigen
philosophin und philosophen sagen es
gibt nur eine form 2011 liegt auch auf
der hand aber wir müssen schauen wie es
damit bestellt ist dann die frage hatte
ich auch schon kurz aufgeworfen gibt es
überhaupt qualität oder nicht vielmehr
nur regula ried und wahrscheinlichkeit
populistischen theorien der kausalität
behaupten dies das sind fragen haben sie
noch weitere fragen die wir mit
aufnehmen sollen
oder sind für sie damit schon einige die
meisten fragen die sie selbst schon
hatten abgedeckt
genau darf ich kurz fragen hat sich
jeder schon die liste eingetragen ist
die liste wieder herum ist uns dürfen
sie die gern noch neu hinzugestoßen
kommilitonen und konventionen danke
geben so das sind zumal die wichtigsten
fragen
das sind natürlich nicht alle fragen ich
kann gleich das zum anlass nehmen und
etwas sagen über die ausrichtung des
seminars meine seminare sind immer
historisch systematisch wir lesen die
historische texte jetzt nicht nur wenn
sie meinen seminarplan schauen den sie
ja auch der flohkiste finden
wir werden das kann man gleich darauf
auch auf sehr viele aktuelle philosophen
eingehen aber mir ist es ganz wichtig
original texte zu lesen ich alles nichts
erst zweiter hand zu beziehen sondern
immer am wirklichen ursprung anzuknüpfen
und diese jeweiligen texte die bei
meinen seminaren auch größtenteils
historisch sind die dann immer zu
befragen also nicht nur einfach alles
wiedergeben sind die texte ganz gezielt
auf ein problempunkt hin lesen und das
sind solche möglichen fragen auf die wir
diese texte hin lesen können vielen dank
ihr hat sich jeder eingetragen von ihnen
ok so also wenn sie noch fragen haben
hierzu können sie die gerne auch noch im
laufe dieser heutigen sitzung einbringen
jetzt habe ich den systematischen teil
vorläufig abgeschlossen zur einführung
jetzt geht's über zum historischen teil
also wie gesagt hier drei punkte hier
können sie noch beliebig weitere fragen
einfügen
was ist kausalität das ist die frage und
die möchte ich jetzt bevor ich zum
ablauf des seminars übergehe ansieht
zurückgeben ich möchte jetzt dass sie
sich fünf minuten zeit nehmen mit ihrem
nebensitzer mit ihre nebensitzerin über
diese frage diskutieren was sie glauben
was qualität ist auch vor dem
hintergrund der punkte die wir jetzt
schon angesprochen haben und dann die
jeweilige andere these also die meinung
ihres nachbarn hier kurz ins plenum